President Biden's border crisis has
exploded Governor Abbot is making big
moves as Texas is drowning in illegal
immigrants he's now flying hundreds of
them to the sanctuary City of Chicago
Illinois people living there have been
unhappy for months now over the
resources flowing to the illegals while
citizens are
struggling just a quick flashback from
not too long ago from black taxpayers in
Chicago watch
how
dare this
mayor and city council have the
guts to give migrants $51 million they
should not be hous in impoverished and
marginalized black and brown communities
where we have food shortages and
homelessness we have not gotten anything
for our community and we are sick and
time tired of being sick and tired
enough is enough okay that was May 31st
can you imagine how they feel today and
they continue in that City the citizens
of Chicago to be vocal and they were
about to get another load of illegal
immigrants now Abbott isn't the only one
sending them there these people come
across the border and they say where
they want to go you saw Bill maluan pop
up uh he's been showing us this on a
daily basis Chicago is one of the places
they want to go and now let's get to the
Border bill maluan is there and you know
Bill when you see how American citizens
are concerned that their own resources
are soaked up over the mass of humanity
that is still standing behind you and
streaming in like water crushing our
nation's sovereignty um you understand
why people are
upset Harris you absolutely do and those
Sanctuary cities better buckle up cuz
they got a lot more coming their way
take a look over my shoulder right now
we had yet another Mass illegal crossing
here in lukeville Arizona this morning
you're looking at hundreds of adult men
from around the world mostly from Africa
waiting for border patrol processing
right now had a chance to talk to some
of these guys they're going all over the
place they told us Minnesota New York
Chicago and New Jersey some of the
cities they're heading to in the United
States and we'll show you how they got
here take a look at this video we shot
this morning they were part of a group
of more than 700 that came through a
breach in the border wall cut by human
Smugglers and crossed illegally here
into lukeville this happens every single
morning out here Harris uh Arizona's
Democrat Governor Katie Hobbs last week
said she was Sting the national guard
down here we've been in lukeville all
week we have not seen a single National
Guard Soldier out here in the area of
these Mass Crossings or helping with
border patrol we don't know where
they're at but you can see what border
patrol is having to deal with every
single morning out here then we'll take
you out to Eagle Pass Texas our Live FOX
News drone over the scene there where
Eagle Pass has been inundated in recent
days as well they had more than 10 ,000
illegal Crossings there in a span of 3
days you can see hundreds of those
migrants still camping out waiting for
border patrol processing they are coming
in from all over the world there as well
agents reporting an Eagle pass they've
encountered folks from Oman Lebanon uh
guiney Albania and Bangladesh it's not
just Venezuela and Guatemala anymore and
that is part of the reason why Governor
Abbott is switching up his game plan
take a look at this video he is now
flying illegal immigrants to Sanctuary
cities this video you're looking at the
very first flight of 120 migrants which
landed at Chicago's O'Hare Airport
Tuesday evening he says he's going to
start flying migrants to Sanctuary
cities and Chicago in particular for
this reason he tweeted this quote
Sanctuary City Chicago started
obstructing and targeting our busing
Mission Texas will now expand our
operation to include flights to Chicago
until Biden steps up to secure the
Border we will continue to provide
overwhelm Texas border towns with much
needed relief and Harris back out here
live it goes out to what you were
talking about at the top of your show
right here uh these Sanctuary cities
brand themselves as sanctuary cities and
they're proud to do so so Texas is
essentially saying well you want them
you're going to get them we're going to
send them your way and uh based off what
we're seeing here in Arizona and in
Eagle Pass Texas those cities better
buckle up because a lot more coming
almost all these people will be Mass
relased yeah and I mean what we've been
learning from you every single day is
that they know the names of the places
that they want to go and and they know
how to get there like they know they're
going to be busted they're going to be
put there so you know the border states
are doing all that they can and they are
sending some people but Bill you've
shown us these people already have
Target cities and they know they are
sanctuaries for them great reporting as
always thank you hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-host Harris
vulner and Kaye mcki on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
sets your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights